that's a very interesting question and I
think the answer is we don't yet know no
but but I do think that I mean for
instance there's this the game that my
13 year old boy Milan and his friends
all seem to be playing right now is this
Wild West game called Red Dead
Redemption you know and one of the
things looking I mean I don't even
pretend to understand what's going on
really but but one of the things that's
interesting about it to me is the much
looser structure of the game and a much
greater agency that the player has to
choose how he will explore and inhabit
the world that's provided for you
he doesn't in fact doesn't really have
to follow the main narrative line of the
game at all for long periods of time
there's all kinds of excursions and
digressions that you can choose to go on
and find many stories to participate in
instead of the magnum at the big story
in the macro story I think that's that
really interests me as a storyteller
because I've always thought that one of
the things that the the internet and the
gaming world permits as store as
narrative as a narrative technique is to
not tell the story from beginning to end
you know to tell stories side ways as to
give alternative possibilities as
something that that the the reader can
in a way choose between you know I've
always thought of the ball his story the
Garden of forking paths as a kind of
model of this that you know the Garden
of forking paths is a is a story it's a
book whose author has gone mad because
what he's tried to do is to offer every
possible variation of every moment you
know so boy meets girl they fall in love
they don't fall in love that's the first
Fork yeah and he wants to tell both
those stories and then every variation
of every moment down both those lines
and of course it's like nuclear fission
that the possibilities explode into
millions and billions of possibilities
and it's impossible to write that book
but it seems to me that in some ways the
Internet is the Garden of forking paths
you know where where you where you can
have myriad variant possibilities
offered at the same level of
of authority if you like so I mean I
think that's one of the ways in which
storytelling could move and these games
these more freeform games in which the
player can make choices about what the
game is going to be you know become a
kind of gaming equivalent of that
narrative possibility
there are legitimate concerns there and
I worry also that there's a dumbing down
factor that you know these these games
are I mean they're they sometimes
require lateral thinking they sometimes
require quite skilled hand-eye
coordination and so on but they're not
in any sense intelligent you know in the
way that you want your children to
develop intelligence they're to make the
mind not just supple but actually
informed and of course if people spend
too much time on this stuff that it
militates against that one of the things
about about lucca and the fire of life
which is basically pro you know in
Rashidah Rashidah Lucas father is
basically fond of the video game and
defends video games - Lucas mother who
is much more skeptical of their value
but there's a bit of a book which also
suggests that that the problem may be
that this way of inhabiting the
imagination may do something harmful to
our relationship to story to the way in
which human beings have always needed
and responded to the art of the story
you know and and that that's not that's
something to be worried about because I
think that there is something about
storytelling that is very intrinsic to
who we are as human beings that one of
the characters in the book refers to man
as the storytelling animal you know and
and so we are we are the only creatures
on the earth who do this so and we may
even I think the hardwired to do it in
the way that we have a language instinct
you know we may actually have a story
instinct and and so there's a there's a
legitimate concern about a new form
which may erode our attachment to the
story what would that do to us as human
beings
you